hello and welcome to the CEO playing dry
hot chick let's play something funky
against the French I'm a little bit sick
of all the trashes this is not the
greatest line ever but okay it leads to
funny play i think i think i have
noticed against this once in some kind
of crazy attack yeah yeah if i take it
you can actually take with the green
check it's funnier because I've made i
have d 4 though no other move right
check so let's just develop what a
strange opening so what you do here can
I go 25 it's a bit late maybe but
somehow I am back in position is looking
a bit shaky and maybe this is enough for
small edge okay Kicks down so let's play
this ending 96 Bishop f3m it still has
to be precise oh okay
what's the deal c4 be five or that it's
not so clear I'm getting lots of stuff
on the queenside okay okay he wants to
go rook c7 I guess obie obie 5v5 without
thinking as you row so if i take a
look-see took f2 okay this idea but you
know at a look-see to King a three look
F to book tix at seven if he goes look
c2 I just played okay one I mean this is
going to be very dangerous with the big
one let's see check you decided on that
extremely quickly as it sa we did you
have those kind of super committal
decisions are done in via instantly
maybe it's know you'll be aight i just
take a seven ok so pratik a seven
ok I definitely want this one and now I
wonder account how do I do this
something like Ruby one rook take the f
to be tool that could be possible let's
try that yeah but okay well okay I see
you
yeah but ok he will take all this stuff
but I have before I should be really
quicker here I should be quicker this is
not about the quantity of the pawns this
is about the speed check
so he will go like b6 rupee one I start
with a 40 mm f4 and I go with the King
right
okay I cannot go b6 here will be seven
through a one
is actually quite slow oh I didn't see
this one correctly check Chandler not so
much about me being quicker yeah what
did i do here oh my god what a
misjudgment crazy crazy what I did check
what is it actually still working
threatening a six on a six takes a seven
and promotes check time morning check
maybe I can actually go there rupee 1 2
g-3 here good work I just didn't have
much time here
check will be two kings e3f to king g
two should work
I'm not killing myself here that would
be check really fitting check you can go
up with the rookie actually
check check check okay so
have to check I don't get down that's
crazy have to go this way how do I win
this year check check check black for
fits on time oh my god whoo wow what an
ending check this for me very tricky to
do check check so we've got this team
very willingly went into this okay are
the computer is always so merciless you
just do this this this and over
essentially that's it so that's pretty
strong he doesn't really have any
counter play yeah ah ok that was it was
easy check yeah I'm kind of curious what
it says about this position probably I
was blundering like no tomorrow I was
really thinking that this must be good
for wide as I'm quickly I the way I
played it was probably completely
atrocious b5 now I didn't go to be 60 b6
group b 1 b 7 in here here and now the
acorn and it looks like a million times
quick i am like what I did
and it is a million times quicker I know
I can come over wow ok again be six days
when I simply never plata and now I
couldn't no I couldn't Oh son check
check I know I'm actually lost check
with f3 I completely janitors completely
don't is so much quicker now check check
check channel which should be
checked.check wanted to try check this
one went back and now I look for is just
winning oh that was easy check it's
funny that the engine gives equal this
this ah ok ok Wow threatening g6 so if I
had promote he actually comes first
check so this is what actually check
check London the game you don't yeah I
probably should go it still had some
some issues here with conversion with
their with no time on the clock I wasn't
quite sure this and then I was irritated
by f2 but i canna can take you for okay
that's what I didn't see it irritated me
a lot but now everything now I was down
to know to check as well check and now I
saw that I'm actually
getting everything wow what a game ok
guys thanks for watching